我今天看到一個案例，很有意思，是德國一家叫 Mika 的公司，他們把傳統稅務服務徹底用 AI 改造了，最近還募了 600 萬歐元。
嗯，稅務喔？這不是高度專業又需要大量人力的服務嗎？感覺這種傳統行業，AI 頂多是輔助吧，要完全取代，你確定撐得住？
他們不是說取代，而是用 AI 原生的平台，把整個稅務申報和管理變成自動化、高效的數位體驗。原文有提到，他們是從零開始重建會計、稅務和財務。
從零開始重建？這聽起來有點出乎意料。一般公司可能都是想著怎麼把現有流程數位化，而不是整個打掉重練吧？為什麼他們會選擇這麼激進的做法？
根據原文 Smedvig Ventures 的 Principal Freddie Kalfayan 說法，德國的會計和稅務對小企業來說特別複雜和昂貴，甚至很多國際大公司都難以立足。這讓小企業沒有真正的替代方案。
難怪他們會有這麼大的痛點想解決。那具體是怎麼做的？AI 真的能處理那麼複雜的德國稅務法規嗎？感覺每年都在變，還很分散。
他們打造了一個 AI 原生的總帳系統，專門為德國會計設計。AI 能讀懂收據和付款，根據任務自動啟動不同的 AI 模型來處理。而且會計師還會在後端檢查。
等等，這裡我有疑問。你說會計師會檢查，那不就還是需要人力？這樣成本真的會比傳統事務所低嗎？他們這樣做的關鍵數字是什麼？
他們說 AI 會自動分類每一筆交易並記錄，還會向使用者解釋每筆分錄的意義，而且通常是「無需人工干預」。只有在複雜情況下，才有受過訓練的會計師介入。
他們還提到，今年年初，大概有 400 家 GmbHs 和 UGs 使用 Mika，現在已經超過 750 家了。而且營收每個月成長超過 20%，七月年化營收就突破 100 萬歐元了。
哇，從 400 到 750，成長很快欸。看起來真的解決了市場的痛點。那如果我是創業者或公司主管，可以從中學到什麼？感覺台灣會計事務所也蠻傳統的。
我覺得最關鍵的，就是不要只是想著把現有的服務「數位化」。而是要思考，如果從頭開始，有沒有可能用 AI 或其他新技術，重新定義整個服務模式，把痛點徹底解決。
意思是，不只優化流程，而是重新思考這個產業的價值鏈？就像 Mika 說的，它不僅是數位化傳統稅務事務所，而是打造一個 AI 原生的金融操作系統。
對，而且他們還提供了傳統稅務事務所做不到的功能，就是讓使用者可以跟自己的數字「對話」。比如說，上傳一封稅務局的信，AI 馬上就能解釋，並告訴你下一步怎麼辦。
這點蠻不錯的，解決了很多小企業主最害怕的、看不懂公文的問題。那一般上班族呢？這個概念能帶入自己的工作或生活嗎？
其實我覺得，我們可以試著檢視自己工作或生活中，有沒有什麼重複性高、規則明確，但又很耗費時間精力的任務？或許可以思考，有沒有 AI 或自動化的工具，能徹底改變它。
嗯，就像那些填表格、整理資料的工作，如果能像 Mika 一樣，讓 AI 幫忙解讀、分類、甚至自動處理，好像真的能釋放很多時間。
對啊。把那些「必要之惡」的行政工作，盡可能交給 AI，我們就能把精力放在更有創造性或更高價值的事情上。這點其實不容易做到，但 Mika 的案例確實給了我們一個新的方向。
聽起來，Mika 的做法不只是在稅務領域，它提醒了我們，任何看似專業且複雜的服務，都有被 AI 徹底改造的可能，只要能找到關鍵痛點，並願意從零思考。
沒錯，感覺也提醒了我們，那些被認為「理所當然」的服務模式，或許才是最容易被顛覆的地方。